these days really prefer to to come and
and establish climatic startups and not
thinking directly is I mean just the
automatic way of thinking of going to
cyber or to fintech they really want to
do something impactful and they think
they they have
they have the the capacity to do that
with the right guidance
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to 20-minute leaders how are you
very well thank you Michael
thank you very much for joining me
um it's a it's really pleasure because
you are working on some really
meaningful things and that's exactly
what this show is about you are the
co-founder and managing partner at
gravityclimate fund and Venture studio
and so I can already tell that there's
two worlds that you're in uh in the from
The Venture Capital space and the fun
but the third world which is combining
them under a the word under Gravity
climate and so obviously with your
background with a PhD in biophysics from
from Weitzman Institute and Masters and
bachelors in chemical engineering from
bengalion it makes sense and uh sounds
like some things that the world needs
these days we just went out of cop 27
pretty much with a bang saying okay we
need to get we need to get some stuff
done and so I'm excited to understand a
little bit about what you're getting
done and the impact that you're having
in your own Journey so again thank you
for being here tell me a little bit
about your connection to you know
biophysics chemical engineering how did
this come about
actually it's funny that you started
with that because when I think of myself
I think you know I I always I mean the
fact that I ended up having a PhD in
Weitzman Institute means that it it goes
without saying that I have the ability
to get excited by science right that
that that's for sure otherwise I
wouldn't I wouldn't have been there but
I think that my models of operandos is
more of an engineer
and uh and in by that I mean when I look
at things I I want to see I look at the
the I want to identify the problems and
then find Creative Solutions to to
resolve those and I don't know if you
know this uh there's a very nice saying
about an engineer there's a uh they they
say when an optimist looks it looks at a
glass he sees it's uh helpful when a
pessimist looks as the glasses sees
itself empty and when an engineer looks
at the glass he says oh it could have
been half its size so yes I think that
that absolutely the kind of things that
uh
um the way that I look at things the way
that I wanna and the way that I access
challenges is how to make the most
efficient solutions that are really
needed
so
that's I think I love it
what guides you yeah okay well tell me a
little bit about gravity climate fund
and Venture Studio you've you've been in
the Venture space for for some time now
and tell me a little bit about you know
Venture for you with that intersection
of from an engineering mindset solving
meaningful problems yeah
so you know in the past couple of years
I spent my time as a principal in IQ
Venture which is a digital Health
focused one and where I learned all the
aspects of being involved with the
Venture investing this is very very
different from being um for my my
previous position in the ministry of
energy where I granted that researchers
and the academic Institute and startups
in their early stages and even pilot and
demonstration projects but it was never
from the mindset of financial objectives
right
and in the VC world it's all about that
and with that in mind I realized that
for doing things I mean that will make a
really
um good and viable startups in the
climate space there are so many things
that has to be taken into account right
I mean building a viable company in in
this space meaning you have a very
strong technology you have a mindset of
commercializing it from the very
beginning you are aware of all the
regulatory framework that you're
entering you have a very creative ways
and different ways to finance your
journey throughout the way with changes
Through Time
and all of those things are things that
are
um in most cases you can't find an
entrepreneur who's just starting a
ventral who has all these capabilities
uh in in-house and within only himself
right
so when we when I thought about
making a VC that will be really
um
instrumental in helping startups grow
and grow the right way I first wanted to
find the the best partner for me for
this journey I mean I come from the very
end is 12 scientific engineering
regulatory background but I I like the
entrepreneur the entrepreneurship and
background and the actual business
experience which is so much needed in
this space and that's how I came about
to meet my co-founders of Leo any so
it's a friend is that is a co-founder in
the managing partner together with me in
this gravity and in in the funded e and
he's really considered to be one of the
most experienced climate entrepreneurs
here in Israel with an outstanding
execution track record he's the
co-founder of enlight renewable energy
which is traded in the Tel Aviv Stock
Exchange is one of the best performing
guests stocks and that's something that
started at 2008 with the two of his
friends and we did all the way from the
the the laptop and that their thinking
and still being and a renewable energy a
producer not only in Israel but only in
Europe and in the US so bringing in
Sofia's experience together with my
experience it actually
answers so many things that
entrepreneurs in the early stages of
venture building in the climate space
really need
so
I love it take me to to your position as
Chief scientist of of Israel's Ministry
of energy and
I'm really curious you know to to from
from a now VC and Venture building you
know mindset what was that like you know
what what what how do you now think
through when you're looking at these
challenges from a more you know National
or or infrastructure Global Perspective
what what did you learn acting as the
chief scientist there that you know we
in the tech world you know so many
different entrepreneurs are going into
climate Tech today for a very good
reason well what are some things that
you take from your experience that are
relevant
and you know in from from now from for
to our knowledge because most people
don't get to work on these problems from
a governmental or a national perspective
yeah so
I think that I mean I was able to see so
many and varied uh Technologies uh and
in really different stages of their
their lifetime I mean I saw things that
are just initiated in the in the
Academia and I saw a technologies that
were just
imported from elsewhere in the world and
didn't didn't need a lot of r d to
implement in the in in to implementing
here but but did need a lot of
regulatory changes in order to to
implement them so uh I it's uh I think
that
my perspective now after seeing so many
Technologies seeing the the the journeys
that researchers have to go through uh
through the and the actual um and basic
research to building a valid prototype
and finding actually the the the right
places to to make the first Pilots the
first demonstration finding their their
pocs partners for for making this and
then later on and thinking about the
right business model to incorporate it
into the the industry uh the the those
are so many challenges that
entrepreneurs have to go through in this
space in particular that I think that
this is something that caused a lot of
um the bad reputation that cleantech had
at the time
because there were many early stage
companies that didn't reach maturation
and didn't really fulfill all their
potential because of all the challenges
that they have to they had faced with
and because at the end they were the the
the the there was not good reception in
the market for such Technologies and
there was not enough willingness to to
pay for this and they were not so it was
like uh
nice to have not a Mastiff as as these
days
but I think that I mean we are now
really at the turning point with
everything that has to do with the with
with climate change I think that there
is no question about whether or not it's
happening there is no question of
whether or not we need more
implementation of existing Technologies
but what is more interesting is that
there is no question that we need to
invent new technologies
and this part is where I think the the
VCS such as such as gravity is coming
into action and it's the creation of new
Ventures that will become the next big
thing then the next big thing is the
next the Teslas the next the Amazons but
in in the climate space
and and for for that as I mentioned I
mean it's it's you cannot expect the
entrepreneurs to know all the what is
expected the what kind of challenges
they're expected to face with
and they need some experts and so some
some people that are veterans from from
this industry you can guide them from
the very
um initial Inception stage
so let's say let's spend some time make
creating some inspiration for
potential technologies that will be
meaningful in the coming years reaching
Net Zero you know take me through your
own perspective on if I was a young
entrepreneur excited to go into climate
tech and and Tackle something that you
know we all need to be worried about
what are some things that I could that I
should be thinking about working on
looking into we can go as high level as
you want or as detailed as you want I'm
I'm with you okay so let me just try to
put it into the right framework so when
we're talking about climate change and
Climate Technologies I we at least think
rapidly look at three different angles
the first one is the the mitigation okay
so in in mitigation uh there is a way to
reduce the actual Ambitions of CO2
either by
creating more novel Technologies for
renewable energies or making the actual
renewable energy more efficient less
costly and more scalable so that's on
the one end and then of course in order
to use the renewable energy and although
their intermediate intermittency and
characteristics you need to add storage
into this uh so there's a lot of new
materials and new methods to make a
storage much more and
costs cost effective
and much more and
compatible to to its uh to its cut to
its use I mean having a large amount if
you look at the what and the
transportation sector so for EVS for
private Vehicles yes there's no no
problem in carrying a battery but when
you're going to into trucks then you
have to find a another way of either
storing the energy or doing or using
another engine such as a hydrogen or or
or or making a well moving their
vehicles through a wireless set roads
that will there transmit the electricity
directly to to the wheels and without
the need for uh for extra and batteries
and so everything that has to do with
the energy generation energy storage and
then Energy Management I mean there are
so many ways in which we can reduce the
actual need to to build more power
plants and even to build more you know
even renewable energy it takes it takes
space right it takes a lot of land it
takes a lot of uh
it's so some people would say that it's
it's not a nice view
I I argue with that but there are some
that that claim such so yes we need to
to find ways in order to manage our
demand for energy in a much more clever
way in order that so we want need to
produce so much energy and also use the
current
um infrastructure that is already in
place such as the the natural gas
infrastructure and use it instead of in
a gas turbines use it with a fuel cells
which are much more efficient which are
much cleaner in in terms of emissions
using those
um
so so everything that has to do with
really mitigating and reducing the
emissions this is in one in one angle on
the other angle comes all the things
that you can do with the CO2 that was
already emitted which is to capture it
and then you can either store it or you
can even use it to neutralize it to
create the new materials and fuels so
it's a way of you know recycling the the
recycling fuels fuels are used emissions
are being emitted but then you capture
the co till and you you you build a new
kind of fuel synthetic fuels which is
called the and then you can use it and
mainly in the that's a great solution
for the aviation industry right because
they cannot use batteries and that I'm
not sure that hydrogen is so easily can
can so easily be implemented in their
Aviation
so that's all that's the part of a
carbon sequestration and but then
there's also when you think about
climate change so and the new era of of
energy you need new you need a lot of
materials that are and you know the the
way to get them is it proves through
Mining and through uh utilizing
resources in our planet and that's also
that that's true for lithium and Cobalt
that are needed for the renewable images
but that's true also for every other
mining materials that we are currently
using regardless of the energy
transition and there are different
different ways to do that you can do
that in a much more efficient way much
more sustainable way that needs a lot
less of water and energy in order to
produce those materials so that's that
and then there is something that we
shouldn't forget about this is that the
adaptation because regardless of what we
are going to do and how successful our
Technologies are going to be and how
much they can reduce the the the the the
admissions to the atmosphere we are
facing a very big and critical and and
effects that the climate change will uh
we create in here in in bit has to do
with all our
all aspects of our life right I mean the
in the most the the there are things
that has to be to do with that you know
there is a different risk assessment
that you have to bring in into all
Industries regarding their supply chain
that will be affected by climate change
there is uh the the need for more
accurate
sensing of climate conditions in
different locations uh we're we're one
would like to live in a in a building
that is facing a road which where the
pollution is so high and where the the
level of
um environmental and measurements are
are very bad so you need to to provide
those those measurements and there's
also I mean things that has to do with
the just adapting to the to the actual
extra demanded energy will be needed in
let's say in residential area areas the
the need for more air conditioning in
this in the summer Etc with and then how
how would you do that with the current
infrastructure you cannot put more
electric it and lines and you cannot
begin and dig under the the current
cities and and streets so you need to
find much better ways either to build
the the buildings in better installation
and such and or and more importantly I
think is the way to manage the
electricity demand in the uh in those
buildings and to use Technologies and
new new technologies such as fuel cells
such as a hydrogen storage just such as
a local energy generation on the
buildings on the walls of the buildings
I mean there are so many ways that can
be done
and on top of all of this there comes
the the digitization
aspect of that I mean to every Hardware
that you can think about in climate you
can make it much more efficient you can
you can scale it much very rapidly you
can bring so much more
advantages the quality student by adding
a digitization and layer to it to that
and that's can be either using Ai and
machine learning for energy management
or it can be using a prediction models
that that will together with the sensors
will be able to predict what what will
be the uh the temperature in the next
day and then to you know be prepared for
for that in terms of
energy generation and such I mean there
are so much so so many things and I
think that
whoever you are and whatever you can
whatever your capabilities are and your
your your interest you can you can apply
it to the to some Climate Technologies
if he wish to and I'm at what I can say
is that I'm really happy to see that
entrepreneurs coming from all
backgrounds and especially the ones and
this is something that we we just
recently started to see especially ones
that come from uh some Elite Israeli uh
technological units such as A200 is just
as yourself and the others special
intelligence units they these days
really prefer to to come and and
establish climatic startups and not
thinking directly is I mean just the
automatic way of thinking of going to
cyber or to fintech they really want to
do something impactful and I think they
they have
they have the the capacity to do that
with the right guidance
it sounds to me that uh
what I'm taking from the last 10 minutes
and thank you for that is um that
there's a lot to do there's a lot of
opportunities there's a lot to do and
um
a lot to think about and in a world
where we are living in this is our world
and uh
it's a it's an interesting it's an
interesting time to be an engineer and
to be at the point at a at a a position
of a of impact where you can move the
needle on something as critical as
literally the word the world that we're
in so thank you very much for the time
the energy your own effort and and the
and everything that you're doing in this
space and thank you for the inspiration
over these specific 20 minutes and I
really appreciate it and they'll
continue cheering and gravity climate
Tech and Venture fun from the side so
thank you very very thank you very much
later